so a piece of advice that i really liked
that you gave was um asking a girl to do
small things for you or pay for small
things and see how she responds
um i think like a lot of guys get into
the trap of like dating a girl that's
just using them for their like money or
their resources
um and i think if a girl isn't willing
to like pay for a coffee every now and
then or like a bottle of wine like
that's probably like a selfish like a
girl that doesn't really care about
anyone other than herself
um so i really liked that piece of
advice that you gave
is that like something that you came
across like personally like did you have
to learn that lesson the hard way or was
that more of like an observation
yeah i've i mean i've um i've been
walking this earth a lot longer than you
and many of the guys that watch my
channel so i'll say this i mean
um
you want to test a woman to make sure
that
um
she's in your frame and that she's
willing to compliment your life so i
mean i think the video that you're
talking about was probably the one where
i was uh suggesting look if you guys you
know if you have a girl coming over
for a date you're several dates in you
know you've been seeing her more than
once obviously
um you know throw a little test at her
and say hey you know do me a favor
um i got dinner sorted out swing by the
liquor store and grab a bottle of this
wine you know on your way over or it's
really hot out you know for me like i
like score mcflurries from mcdonald's
it's like my one you know vice right i
try to stay away from sweets and crap
like that for the most part but i might
say hey look you know do me a favor on
your way over grab me a nice score
mcflurry and if she protests if she
gives you a hard time about i ain't
gonna do nothing like that for no man
you know some of this nonsense
and that's a pretty good sign that you
don't want to spend too much time with
this check on a long-term basis you keep
her at arm's length length and she might
just be a plate if that's what it is
that you want to do but you certainly
don't want to invite a woman in your
life if she can't comply with something
basic like that because when it comes to
other things later on down the road and
she's going to protest or push back or i
don't need no man for you know like none
of that nonsense it's really just a test
you know how when i talk about women
kind of [ __ ] test men a bit this is you
know this is a bit of a test to make
sure that she's compliant and that she's
in your frame that's all that really is
can you define a [ __ ] test for me like i
don't i don't actually even know what
that is
yeah that's a good question so it's
really just a competency test um
you'll see it all the time once you
understand what it is you know what it
is it's like uh
i mean if a guy can't change a tire for
example in a car and there's a flat tire
and she starts chirping on him because
they're stuck at the side of the road
and he doesn't know how to put the jack
together to jack up the car and you know
flip it out she's going to start
chirping on him and grinding his gears
about it and that's a bit of a [ __ ] test
she wants to know that she's with a
competent guy that can do things and
that can be any number of things so
when when women
basically uh do this to a guy and
they'll do it less and less once they
realize that he is the hypergamous best
option for her right like she's not
gonna [ __ ] test him that much after that
point or after that points realized in
her head but it's it's just her natural
innate interest in making sure this guy
isn't a fraud basically
i'm like trying to think if i've ever
done that oh [ __ ] i guarantee you have i
guarantee you
i'm like trying to think um
okay um i also got a good piece of
advice that you have um because what i
liked about your channel is you actually
offer some solutions um where a lot of
like redtail channels are just like
you know women are the worst don't date
walk away um
you know unless you're chad it's over
for you
well those are the black pill guys those
aren't those aren't my friends
um but one piece of advice that you used
was finding women like through common
interests as opposed to like going out
to a bar or a club
um i thought that was a really good
piece of advice because like
you know clearly
the type of girl that's gonna like that
that her hobby is drinking like that's
not gonna be a girl that like puts other
things
you know like what what skills does that
bring you like what like how does that
make you a wife or like a good mother
just going to the bars and like clubbing
every weekend
yeah right so that's one of the
complaints a lot of guys make about
women is they're not particularly keen
on the
quality of what they might uh meet in a
social venue like a nightclub or a bar
um
and
guys are always like well you know how
do i find
a good girl sort of thing like well
first of all understand there's you know
stop stop looking for the unicorns
because they generally don't exist so
let's just set that aside for a minute
but just do what you like you know like
if you like driving fast cars join an
exotic car club there's not going to be
a lot of women there but guess what when
you trip across them at certain events
they're pretty much stunners and they
want to be there because they want to be
around top shelf men that have chased
excellence put a dent in the universe
and on our
like some kind of purpose they like
being around people like that so you're
not going to have you know the same
number of women to approach and talk to
at a club like that but they will show
up from time to time and they're a
better fit for you and your interests
with what you're doing because they're
already in that frame now it's just okay
is she going to enter my frame and
compliment my life if that's what
they're looking to do
um
no and i think that's why like i don't
really have a lot of friends with like
those crazy stories that you see on like
fresh and fit and like those different
platforms it's because like most of my
friends i
met through athletics so like i was a
three sport college athlete so that's
like where i found most of my friends
um and so like on the weekends like a
lot of my friends are going
like to a volleyball game or like
basketball like whatever it is
yeah right and and those like girls you
see on shows like that they're not
i mean
they're kind of doing a bit of a
disservice because it's like they get
these girls drunk and they get these
women with you know with bad attitudes
and they put them up there and they're
like okay let's make an example that's
that's not all women i mean that's how
many women can and do behave but there
are women out there that don't act like
that right
yeah and i actually like after fresh and
fit i started dming or like messaging
like the pr like the most attractive
girls that were on like sports teams of
mine so mine over the years and just
asking them has a guy ever like offered
to fly you out and i literally could not
find one person i'm not saying it
doesn't exist but like
um i think sometimes like the disservice
like the manosphere kind of does is they
don't really
like offer the perspective from just
like average people that don't live this
like crazy life
you probably haven't watched enough of
my videos to realize that i call it the
mantle swamp there's a reason why i call
it the manual swap
um okay another good piece of advice i
thought you had was don't date single
mothers i think that's just common sense
um i don't know like why girls get
defensive um anyone that has a brother
if like
like i have five brothers so i would
never tell them to pick a single mother
over a girl who didn't have kids i think
that's just common sense
yeah there's really nothing to debate
there i mean
i know lots of women that that have
younger siblings that you know that are
men and they're
really pissed off that they get
entangled with these single mommies
sometimes
they get sucked down this like vortex of
a nightmare life that they that they
have a hard time getting out of and guys
are bred to believe that they should
behave like captain sabaho and they
swoop in to protect the honor of milady
and you know it doesn't matter that i'm
not the dad but i'm the dad that stepped
up you know like you see like you see
and hear all these narratives and
it's one of the worst things that guys
can do is to
surrender
you know themselves to a single mommy
and raise the offspring of some other
dude or in some cases she's got
three kids in tow from three different
men
guys that do that do it because they're
low-hanging fruit and it's easier than
doing the work on themselves
making something out of themselves and
being on a purpose right like they would
have a lot more options if they did that
and and hey listen you know like i'm
speaking from experience too like i've
dated single mommies like i got into an
ltr with a single mommy for a few years
it's about the dumbest thing i ever did
in my life
um what do you think about like girls
dating a guy with kids do you feel the
same way like if you had a daughter
would you tell her to avoid guys with
well it's a different story you know
again so there's a lot of okay well men
and women are the same so let's talk
about the differences between single
mommies and single daddies
some of the big differences are when
a woman is a parent
she often has custody of the kids about
80 of the time so if you're a single guy
dating a single mommy you're probably
gonna end up spending more time with
that guy's kids than what he does okay
so that's one big difference another big
difference is women parentally invest
into children for nine months in their
bodies they birth them and then they
have to raise them right men don't need
to do that there's a big difference in
the state of my body versus a woman's
body after she's had three kids and
let's say that i'm a single dad with
three kids there's a big difference
between the state of me and her
another big difference is men generally
speaking choose careers that pay a lot
more money
right so i'm gonna be making a lot more
money than what most single mommies make
right so there's a lot of big
differences i mean you can't say
well if you tell guys not to date single
mommies then you should tell you know
girls not to date single fathers well
one of the interesting things about
single fathers is
something called pre-selection and
if you've got a kid good-looking kid you
know you pair bonded with a nice-looking
woman you made a nice child you've got
priest selection that actually looks
favorable to quite a few women
so it's not it's not the detriment that
a lot of guys think that it can be